und damit herzlich willkommen meine
lieben freunde hier zu einer runde chris
range adventure ich habe überhaupt
keinen plan was das ist das war nur
gerade auf seiner website ganz oben und
stand chris rudge adventure und hab ich
mir gedacht ein wetterhahn ich gar kein
bock mich aufzuregen aber hier steht
pressed to play jazz clique kempf eine
wir klicken mal hier
dollar la haye ein mustertext in julie
christie start geht gar nichts einfach
so arrow keys to move okay ich kann auch
springen ok ok einer das ist so als wenn
man einfach so kommen
das ist echt sowie schlittschuhfahren
zwicker das ist uns das kann man nicht
schafft man diese krise hautkrebses
langsam auch krebs bei aldi wartet so
jetzt kann streamer ich bin jetzt hier
hoch jetzt hier so bin ich hier und
freunde alter ich muss doch einfach nur
sorry übrigens ein bisschen hakt oder
irgendwie so aber bei mir ruckelt auch
krass das ist ja nicht das ist einfach
ein richtiges geld auch heute schon
einmal diese musik an
ich hab's im gefühl dass der sec schaffe
wenn ich dieses level hier drin hab ja
ja aid er springt sich der bilder nicht
hoch allein diese tatsache dass es
zwischendurch wieder richtig das ist
doch nicht wahr alter
haben die keine anderen motivlage oder
dann nahm ich will wieder am start
das kann doch nicht sein ich hatte schon
so oft spiele die mich echt ammann an
den rand der verzweiflung gebracht haben
minecraft beispiel das kann doch nicht
sein
daneben war es ist so schönes wetter
draußen sie drin und zog jetzt diese
scheibe ende wird es sicherlich muss am
wenigsten er dieses level hinkriegen so
schwer ist das doch nicht das ist doch
so hier hoch hier gewann im moment das
ist jetzt noch nicht so schlimm soll
hier drauf jetzt springen wir jetzt
springen da ist er ganz langsam an die
plattform rettet
wie kann ich den rappen hier wurde mir
irgendwann mal gesagt wenn ich etwas was
krabbeln kann niveaus nicht also ende
easy trax von facc alter obwohl das
finde ich geht noch hier ist nicht so
der typ ist nicht so schnell gerade
dangerous ich stehe doch gerade auf den
spikes hey hey hey hey
hey
das ist nicht wahr das kann man nicht
schaffen das level
ich weiß nicht wie ich das geschafft
habe aber die gingcom jetzt habe darauf
hier alter freunde da unten ist ein
geheim weg ich war so mal eben den
geheimcode zu kriegen ja doch noch so
drauf drauf drauf ich geh jetzt mal den
oberen das ist und dass von hier über
das ich habe ihn nicht berührt
junge jedoch einfach auf diese scheiß
platte drauf so hier guck hier drauf
hierüber sagt hierüber noch kein ding
und ich bin überhaupt nicht begeistert
von dem spiel
ich probiere es nochmal den oberen weg
das ist doch nicht war aber an dieser
typ sind einfach genauso aus wie jogi
von yu-gi-oh so warte jetzt bin ich hier
kann man dann kann daraus theoretisch
auch ein remix jetzt hier eben rüber
hier auf die raptor und jetzt das kann
doch nicht sein ich habe echt noch nie
so ein dummes spiel erlebt ich weiß noch
als ich damals damit gespielt wo ich
nicht weiter gekommen da war das spiel
zumindest noch vernünftig hier ist es
einfach nur so ein scheiß spiel vor
allem diese tatsache ja die spikes sind
gefährlich manchmal wenn ich drauf bin
ich direkt tot
manchmal überlege ich einfach noch die
ganzheit der typ schlittert einfach
wieder ein [ __ ] gehen jetzt auch 1
234 drauf jetzt hier und jetzt dieses
level ist das allerletzte was ich noch
fertig machen will mehr will ich von
diesem spiel ist jetzt etwas wie soll
ich das denn schaffen auch verdammte
scheiße
guckt euch das an dance geld so jetzt
hier drauf und da ist das ziel ich das
jetzt schaffen soll ich keine ahnung
so jetzt hier
wie soll ich das denn wissen alter nicht
irgendeinem augenkrebs kriegen sollte
dann hundertprozentig wegen dem zocken
von diesem spiel spring doch verdammt
ich wollte neue tastatur ja so und jetzt
ja und jetzt und jetzt ich bin nicht so
gegen das ist doch nicht wahr freunde
ich pack und jetzt mal in slow motion
hier rein dass ich nicht jetzt kommt die
motion
die taktik so aber ich manche sagen
echte wahl das kann doch nicht so schwer
hat nur in lucka guckt in die
beschreibung dasteht link zu der scheiße
das ist doch das ist einfach unfair
ich bin ich springe nicht genau wieder
nicht gegen gesprungen das spiel halt
einfach schon so vorher auf ja du
schaffst es eh nicht so darüber so
keinen sinn da wäre ich auch nicht gegen
gesprungen
so jetzt musst du zu den hier soll der
jetzt spiele ich hier über so ich
verklage dieses spiel und hole mir soll
gutmann als anwalt aller welt ist nicht
wahr auch neue taktik ich hierhin und
jetzt hier über ok das geht zumindest
immer klar jetzt nein jetzt geht das
auch nicht mehr klar oder wie so und
jetzt hier in die lücke nein natürlich
kann mich nicht in die lücke reihen
es war doch klar das ist doch nicht
freunde so komm jetzt gehe
ich hasse dich spieleentwickler box ist
ja meine lieben freunde das war es dann
auch hier mit dem spiel hieß nummer
chris rudge adventure ich nee ich gebe
auf ich mache jetzt hier kommt ich mache
jetzt jedoch ob es jetzt habe ich
irgendwas verstellt bestimmt gerade eine
ist es geht auch gar nicht mehr ich muss
einmal kurz hier jetzt geht es ja zumal
wenn ich das jetzt schaffen das wäre so
unfassbar freunde es kann nicht sein ich
berühre diese scheiß zecken nicht und
ich bin verdammt noch mal tot obwohl ich
sie nicht berühre das hat mich an diese
scheiß mario kart spiele von damals wo
man dann irgendwo gegen pferde man ist
eigentlich gar nicht gegen gefahren weil
die wand erst in zehn jahren kommt aber
egal wie es mir ist egal
wenn ihr mehr von irgendwelchen
komischen spielen einfach so sehen wollt
von so zwischendurch spielen weil die
sind für mich leichter aufzunehmen da
muss ich nicht so viel recherchieren wie
bikes oder command oder crafting ideen
oder mops oder wird werde ich sondern
einfach nur so zocken das ist schon
irgendwie interessant aber bei solchen
spiels ist dann natürlich echt wieder so
ne andere sache
da muss man dann natürlich auf jeden
fall auch die nötigen nerven mit an den
start bringen
das ist deine freunde ich las seine
kommt noch das macht er auch irgendwie
schon ein bisschen süchtig dieses spiel
so ihr habt gesehen ich bin dort nicht
in die zacken gelaufen und ich bin tot
wir sehen uns ging mal wieder